on the white cliffs of dover looking out
across the english channel which
separates britain from france 600 people
crossed this narrow stretch of water by
boat on wednesday not a huge figure in
the scheme of things but under pressure
boris johnson is determined to be seen
to be doing something to stop the
dangerous journeys it's a busy ship in
london
and so more than 6 000 kilometers away
in kigali his home secretary announced
an ambitious deal with the rwandan
government
in theory anyone who enters the uk via a
so-called illegal route may be sent to
rwanda to have their claim for asylum
processed those who are resettled will
be given the support including up to
five years of training with the help of
integration accommodation health care so
that they can resettle and thrive
the rwandan government's getting an
initial payment of roughly 156 million
dollars
it says it'll offer people protection
and a chance to rebuild their life even
if their asylum claim is unsuccessful
many rwandans
have experienced what it means to be
displaced
this has shaped how we approach
migration and asylum
rwanda already provides a refuge for
almost 130 000 refugees from
multiple countries
including neighbors like the drc and
burundi
as well as afghanistan and migrants
evacuated from libya thank
despite the uk's warm words about
rwanda's offer boris johnson says the
scheme should act as a deterrent to
people thinking of crossing the channel
whatever the case is accepted there will
be legal challenges in many eyes it's a
clear breach of the 1951 united nations
refugee convention
beyond that opposition politicians and
some conservatives from johnson's own
party have called the whole idea immoral
unworkable and a huge waste of money
this government needs to create more
safe routes it needs to be looking at
creating a humanitarian visa system for
example where people can claim asylum in
a country such as france in an embassy
there um so that they don't have to put
their money and their lives in the hands
of people's mothers there are many other
options to this process this issue um
than people having to use people
smugglers or when they arrive here being
flown over to somewhere six thousand
miles away
it's far from clear how much this scheme
will cost beyond practicalities many
have expressed amazement at the choice
of rwanda
last year britain itself called for
independent investigations into
allegations of extrajudicial killings
deaths in custody enforced
disappearances and torture in the
country
and rights groups have drawn parallels
with australia's experience of
offshoring asylum seekers saying sending
them to rwanda will simply increase the
risk to their physical and mental health
nadine barber al jazeera
vicky hawkins is uk executive director
of doctors without borders she's
concerned how refugees and migrants will
cope with being sent to rwanda
our real concern is about the physical
and mental harm that offshoring refugees
and migrants in this way causes to
people people that make the crossing on
the channel they're already vulnerable
and traumatized people
they need protection and our work in
similar situations where people have
been where refugees and migrants have
been offshored such as uh on narrow when
the narrow when the australian
government implemented the same policy i
mean it was very evident to us that was
some of the worst mental health
suffering we've seen in all of our
programs around the world so that the
impact on already traumatized people is
just enormous